salut à tous c'est pêcheurs de trésor
alors aujourd'hui on est sous un énorme
pont très prometteur on est dans une
petite ville ouais petite ville mais
bien passante et puis il y avait déjà
des cartouches de calibre 12 au bord
c'est un très bon indice ça montre que
ça a été fait mais il en reste toujours
et puis peut-être qu'ils ont pas trouvé
le fusil
ouais c'est super lourd
enfin après là pour le soulever
l'autre côté
ah ouais débloque les mains et on fait
basculer
allez sors nous le
bah voilà on a pas commencé encore à
pêcher et Quentin est déjà dans l'eau ça
s'annonce bien
elle a pas l'habitude
voilà parfait OK
tu vois que c'est du beau matin
une sorte de draisienne quelque chose
comme ça relativement
bon anniversaire
si vous avez des idées il y a toujours
des pros en commentaire qui peuvent
reconnaître le moindre objet donc là je
vous le film bien si vous avez des idées
continue
dans le crash pour le
bonne dépollution bonne dépollution
comme dirait Quentin
ah oui une petite cuillère de pêche
quand même
ça c'est un micro
50 centimes de francs de quelle année
[Musique]
nous sommes aujourd'hui à Agen Quentin
ouais comme les pruneaux pour une petite
partie de pêche à l'aimant voilà on
était très constipé on a décidé de
s'arrêter et puis finalement on a aussi
décidé de pêcher un peu
regardez là une moto non une voiture ah
ça va te plaire c'est une sorte de
camion en jouet il a pris cher
mais ça devait être un joli camion je
pense bah ce spot il m'a l'air bien il y
a des choses Baptiste
qu'est-ce que c'est que ça
ouais ok
mais c'est pas tout c'est pas tout
je sais ça aussi
c'est pas une matraque ça
c'est une matraque
et ça m'est servi
ça fait plaisir
pour le coup c'est une première
avec notre matraque là ça ressemble oui
nous demandez pas pourquoi on a des
armes c'est juste pour comparer si
jamais on en trouve
ok mais ça va la servi hein tu vois que
la servi mais la plupart des matelas
je pense
qu'elle est morte
qu'est-ce que tu nous trouves un peu
plus lourdes j'espère
qu'est-ce que c'est ça Quentin je
regarde il y a des piles non ton cœur
une munition surtout ah non ah non
j'ai cru
c'est quoi
super il y a la plaque donc on va
appeler la police pour voir si elle est
volée je pense que oui
en fait
pas mal d'objets qui viennent pas
forcément
allez je vais essayer de tirer quand tu
as sur la patte blanche d'en face
non
une petite fourchette en cuillère
cuillère
voilà j'ai quelque chose les gars
c'est dans les algues
ah c'est un aimant ça
je crois mais
si je dis pas de bêtises
mais ça peut être intéressant
c'est plein de coups
alors ouais ouais
le truc c'est un truc de caddie
plein de choses plein de choses
ça c'est vieux ça
c'est
ça
oh un cadre fin de fourche de vélo
attention
et
encore un morceau du vélo
ancien
vérifie sur les mains
depuis 1998
c'est ton année de naissance non
pas mal donc c'est là depuis un bon
moment et avec ça regardez on a fait ça
à mon avis c'est
un truc électrique
il y a du câble électrique
et voilà bon je continue ici il y a pas
mal de choses en m'éloignant du pont
avec plus grosse
par rapport à faire
bonne question en vrai
et une plaque en fonte
de cheminée ou je sais pas quoi tu vas
réussir non je vais te faire voler tu es
prête
ok super
on a bobine de cuivre là
oh oui ah ça c'est un Tamagotchi non
c'est pas ça
aussi à garder c'est rigolo pour ceux
qui connaissent pas c'est une sorte de
petit animal qu'on devait nourrir
voilà regardez une pile déjà belle des
pollution on va la mettre là-bas une
cuillère
bon ben ça on va garder aussi de toute
façon on garde les couverts
et ça c'est
ouais
et ça c'est un filtre à gasoil donc ça
n'a absolument rien à faire dans l'eau
et encore un morceau du vélo
qui est vraiment démonté en petits
morceaux
de vélo
une jolie cuillère
stand
voilà
juste le manche est original mais c'est
vrai que c'est un peu moche quand même
et c'est tout plat
ouais c'est de la merde
et voilà donc encore un morceau de mon
vélo
alors le couteau
ah mais celui-là tu vois il est beau
pour une fois
il a été
aiguisé avec ce que tu nous sors de beau
encore un outil tu sais une clé une
grosse clé à molette
mais je préfère
alors qu'est-ce que j'ai moi
oh mais oui c'est bon ça c'est un
aspirateur non non
ça me rappelle ma mère quand tu es coupé
le rôti
et ça c'est pour démonter les pneus il
me semble
ouais tu le veux aussi
et une énorme cuillère avec l'hameçon
un sachet
avec quelque chose à l'intérieur
est-ce que c'est juste un prospectus
qu'est-ce qui nous a trouvé encore une
grille de barbecue j'ai l'impression
une toute petite grille de barbecue
parfait
qu'est-ce qu'on a
un aimant encore mais cette fois-ci un
vrai aimant je crois même pas de pêche
mais
toujours dans la plupart j'ai cru je
vais voir
ouais mais il est tu sais il a la forme
creuse là
très légèrement très léger
encore un bout de vélo je pense et ça
c'était un colis de chien ouais
ça c'est parfait ça pour signer regarde
tiens
encore une voiture ah ouais ça c'est
bien par contre
mon leurre de pêche
c'est comme les voitures dans la
carrière ils ont enlevé les roues
plus facile à remonter tu vois que tu as
déjà remonté une voiture entière
ah bah c'est ça ton titre de la vidéo ma
première voiture entière
encore des morceaux de ton vélo
ça c'est pour les vélos possible
allez le dernier lancer en espérant
avoir mieux qu'un morceau de vélo
encore ce truc blanc là
c'est un manche à balai peut-être qui
s'est fait couper en plein de boue
puis pas grand chose voilà cette vidéo
touche à sa fin là je vais faire la
dernière remontée j'espère que ça vous a
plu pour nous en tout cas c'était un
super fond on espère y revenir parce que
il y avait plein de choses ouais c'est
certain il reste plein de choses ici
allez c'est le dernier lancer il est
encore plein quoi
après voilà il y a beaucoup de petites
ferrailles pas très intéressant mais une
fois que tu as qu'on a sorti toute cette
série là c'est pas impossible qu'il y
ait des choses intéressantes au fond
ça brille Sabri ah non c'est la même
déjà sympa voilà bon ben à la semaine
prochaine pour une nouvelle vidéo de
pêche à l'aimant